is never changed to make it look
different only to make it work better
that was a commercial for the Volkswagen
Beetle a car seen on roadways from
Germany to California for more than 80
years but the Beatles long ride is about
to come to an end in March VW announced
its planning to end production of the
iconic model that won't change the love
many owners have for their bugs however
or the lively business at one of the few
auto shops dedicated exclusively to
repairing them Don Dahler paid them a
visit
[Music]
they are the humblest of cars designed
in Germany in the 1930s they gained
popularity as part of the 60s
counterculture Volkswagen Beetles are
notoriously underpowered offered with no
frills a basic design that didn't
markedly change for decades but they are
arguably the most popular cars in
history
once you Bick with us on America's
highways bugs are now a cherished rarity
just ask these proud owners taking part
in an annual fall foliage cruise on the
East Coast organized by Chris pollone we
had 50 cars and probably 85 90 people
showed up people come from all over the
country I have a guy that flies in from
California every year to do that cruise
this is a beauty yeah
1962 convertible Valon is himself a bug
fanatic with his father Chris senior he
runs classic VW bugs in Congress New
York perhaps the only restoration shop
in the world dedicated solely to the
lowly beetle what is it like for you
when you find that that hidden treasure
somewhere that's a barn find or has just
been sitting in the guy's field forever
it's magical it really is because you
just don't see much of them anymore but
to find something like that in a barn
it's just so cool for Valon this 1968
Volkswagen Beetle was the one that
started it all $350 later I bought that
and brought home to my dad I said I
think I'm gonna restore this one let's
give it a shot what is it about the bug
that it that appealed to you that happy
look on his face
it's got a face when you look at it
right it's got the little smile and a
bumper there there's still a very safe
vehicle yeah for the most part they had
little knowledge of auto mechanics at
the time but over the years the villains
have managed to grow classic VW bugs
into the destination for bug enthusiasts
looking to have their baby restored or
looking to buy one already transformed
to showroom quality how long would it
usually take you though to restore want
it it depends you know how bad the car
is if it's a real rust bucket sometimes
would be six months eight months a year
is it difficult to get parts for things
that are 50 years plus old you know
thank God for the Internet it was said
internet specifically eBay that got the
word out about the Valon shop now they
have a two-year waiting list for cars
that once upon a time cost as little as
fifteen hundred dollars what do some of
these high-end restorations go for now
an old one like a 54 or 55 something
like that you're talking 40 50 $60,000
$65,000 I'm a split window I've seen
split windows 7075 why do you think
though that people are still drawn to
these in nostalgia the history people
want their youth back and they want
those memories back
something the lucky few who never gave
up those memories can understand even
this reporter who still owns the bright
red beetle his parents drove off the lot
in 1967 for $2,000 for CBS this morning
Saturday Don Dahler Kongers New York
good for da my dad had one lime allure
it was like a pale yellow Volkswagen
Beetle and I hated getting into it as a
kid because it was like no frills and
you could smell the gasoline burning in
the back you know they that the engine
was like was the engine in the back yeah
I think it was back on the car you know
but he should have kept it I'd probably
be looking styling drove one once and
just smile